can you guess where I am I'll give you a
clue it's not Nottingham I'll tell you
more at the end of the video but in the
meantime the main purpose of this video
is an interview with another science
youtuber something we occasionally do
here on 60 symbols and this one well
he's probably one of the most popular of
all the science youtubers and something
else interesting in this video is we'll
show you the YouTube clip that inspired
him to become a youtuber hello I am
Michael Stevens I created and I host
Vsauce which is the first of three
channels that we currently have the
channels investigate weird questions and
we look at the science and math and
history and geography of interesting
things and by interesting I mean
anything a big point of the channels is
that even the most boring little thing
can be amazing Brady Haran you are an
example I use for this you did a video
on how paint dries because we're gonna
talk about watching pans right and
microscopically speaking drying paint is
complicated and it is so cool and it
makes you appreciate the things that you
look at but yeah we've been really
fortunate and our audience is amazing
and it's grown faster than we ever
expected I mean I was at comic-con last
year emailing Kevin from Vsauce to
saying we're gonna hit 700,000 soon and
now we're at 2.4 million it just blows
your mind but it makes you realize how
hungry people are for cool information
and cool thoughts and that they not only
want to watch content like this but they
want to share it I don't have a masters
or a higher degree from a graduate
school I have a bachelor's in neuro
psychology from the University of
Chicago and a bachelor's in English
literature so I was working on some
pretty cool projects about religion and
politics in the brain at the same time I
got a grant from my school that I'd
applied for to make really funny videos
why because I saw a video on YouTube
called shining and it was made in
probably 2006-2007 we're talking very
early days of YouTube a guy took the the
horror movie The Shining and
cut it into a trailer that made it look
like a feel-good family comedy about
warmth and love and adoption and
children and parents and it blew my mind
in 2006-2007 such a thing had never
existed
maybe Letterman would have something
like that but for all you knew it was
made by you know a huge production team
shining was made by one guy for one
competition and he warped the entire
movie and to have that kind of power I
thought I've got to do this I've got to
learn how to edit and the first projects
that I made were literally copies of
that format I took Ferris Bueller's Day
Off and I made it look like a horror
film so I watched the movie and I made
notes of all the scary moments people
yelling people kicking things when
Cameron like punches the car seat if you
add in the screams of a woman every time
he hits it it becomes terrifying so I
made this long story short deep that
video wound up this is not gonna be long
story short this is short story long but
that video wound up on college humor
calm and Jeff Rubin from CollegeHumor
personally emailed me he's like I love
your stuff like send it directly to me
and that amount of encouragement was all
I needed I applied for the grant and I
used this money just to spend a summer
making episodes about politics because
the election Barack Obama's 2008
election was happening at that time so
that's how I got into video I was
discovered by been relased who created
barely political and I worked as a
cameraman for them and then after the
election the key of Awesome's started on
barely political I'm not musical so I
said look maybe I could do like a video
game channel
I used a random name generator to come
up with the name Vsauce it meant nothing
it could become anything and it became
not a video game channel but a channel
where I discussed the things that I
loved the time that I spent researching
why do people have different eye color I
can actually turn it into an episode I
guess it began when I started a show
called boat which was short for best of
all time because there was one topic
that I really loved and it was hot sauce
I was a hot sauce
I bought the hottest sauce from the
little Mexican markets in Brooklyn and
we're talking like painfully hot it got
to the point where it was affecting me I
was getting heartburn and I had to stop
but I was that passionate about hot
sauces and I researched why they were
hot and why certain things helped the
heat go away milk helps because it has a
special enzyme that breaks down
capsaicin let's begin with what makes
hot peppers hot a chemical called
capsaicin capsaicin is an oil which is
why water doesn't help get rid of the
spiciness but alcohol will because
alcohol will help mix in with that that
oil whereas water won't I thought this
was fascinating and so I made an episode
of what's the hottest pepper of all time
boat and it was so fun and it did quite
well and I was so proud of it that I
said I want to do more of these and so I
did what's the loudest noise possible
what's the biggest hole on earth just
kind of a funny title which like when
you hear that title how can you not
click on it at this point all the ideas
for the episodes come from conversations
I have with friends other people that I
that do educational videos which are a
great source of inspiration because they
they know things that I don't they
mention these things casually and it
blows my mind and I'm like this is an
episode right and so I'll take a little
nugget here and I'll get there I'll look
through notes that I've taken after I've
read books I keep draft emails of ideas
I've had and I'll scan through those and
see if anything's related and from that
stitch together an episode that can fall
under a common theme and can be labeled
with usually a question a title that
asks a question that when read the
potential viewer just can't help but
click on because well now the questions
in your mind you don't know the answer
and you want to know I know that a video
is ready to go into production when I
need to put a video out so if I need to
put one out tomorrow then the episodes
gonna have to come out tomorrow and that
means that I'm done Wikipedia is amazing
and I've found that despite some of it's
sort of stereotypes it winds up being
one of the most reliable up-to-date
sources for instance
we discover a new prime number the the
largest prime number okay well if you go
to educational sites or College websites
have they updated yet probably not and
so when I use those resources I actually
will double-check them with Wikipedia
because it's it's something that
everyone can edit one case in in
particular I was looking for the longest
word that you could type using just one
row of a keyboard well I found a great
site all about word facts and I thought
I had an answer I checked on Wikipedia
and it's some Scrabble conference in
2011 some genius had discovered a word
that technically was a word and could
also be typed on one row but that hadn't
made it to these other sites that were
updated by like individual webmasters so
so Wikipedia is a it's a good place to
go it's a good place to start then I go
on to academic papers I read a lot of
those i watch a lot of lectures and a
lot of videos that other people have
made and I love it because I can then
shout out their videos as resources
putting them in the description or
saying where I found it and it's great
because you can form relationships with
these people just by sort of sending
your viewers over to them and it's like
saying hello but instead of a you know
bouquet a roses you've got a bouquet of
viewers who might become subscribers
you've got such a big audience do you
worry about being wrong yes I worry
about being wrong and if I'm ever
worried I will double-check with people
who are brilliant minutephysics Henry
from minutephysics has helped me out
with some Skype conversations before PhD
comics as well they'll put me in touch
with Oh will we know this this one guy
who's working on that exact problem and
I'll call and usually the questions are
so weird people are like don't really
know the answer but let's make sure
we're in the right direction I am very
careful to clarify things using
annotations if I need to but luckily I
haven't needed to do that very often
look at the stuff that I did before I
moved to the UK before I realized how
global the audience was I'm using only
real units because I wasn't even
thinking that 60% of my audience was not
in America
and so now I'm I'm constantly thinking
of how can I make sure this applies to
everybody
I'm definitely sourcing a lot of
questions and criticisms from Twitter
from the comments and I've got them in
mind I kind of you know I think about
what they might like and what they might
share and what I think that they should
know you spend a lot of time talking
about great discoveries and scientists
and things people doing research and it
clearly really inspires you you started
down a path you debt university you did
bit of research do you ever wish you
were playing the game instead of
commentating on it well obviously I mean
the guys who play the game are the
heroes I'm just the guy who's like well
look what that hero did but I wasn't
great at playing the game I'm not
organized enough I'm not good enough to
do that type of stuff I could explain
things and I could generate enthusiasm
around them and luckily I found an
outlet for that to really point people
to what these heroes are doing I would
love to be able to do more
demonstrations it's tough because I'm my
own cameraman there's no team that works
on Vsauce it's just me researching and
then I perform the whole thing with a
camera an arm's reach away and then I
edit the footage and so it's it's
difficult for me to say all right I'm
gonna have a cameraman come out with me
and we're gonna blow this thing up or
we're gonna watch the sunset and talk
about the the way the Sun works I don't
know but I can't do those demonstrations
as easily I would love to do more of
those I think that there are so many
channels on YouTube though that are
doing them well that I'm also happy just
saying go watch what these people did
it's amazing
so where am I and Michael well we're
both here in Palm Springs for the
tedactive conference as guests of ted-ed
and we're very happy guests too because
it's unbelievably sunny